yeah so we lost like we lost like a
couple deals the past couple weeks
to companies that are charging like 200
a month you know retainer and we're like
we're [ __ ] better than these we're so
much better than these companies we give
more we're like
we coach better oh everybody can make
them more money and they're like [ __ ]
go with this company or because they're
200
a month so i would so so tj so if you
were if you were on the phone and you're
like hey alex
there's this guy down the street for two
hundred dollars a month i'd be like hey
man i was like what do you sell personal
training for
200 a month right training for right
i mean you would the guy would tell him
he'd be like i don't know 80 bucks an
hour like cool
i got a kid down the street he'll do it
for 10 bucks whose training do you think
is better
why do you think he's got to charge 10
right get what you pay for and so that
being said if you want to go there the
thing is is if you spend 200
to get nothing is that a better
investment than spending a thousand
in getting 10x on it so is it really a
cost if we're looking at how much money
we're going to make
when you invest in a stock are you like
well amazon's more expensive than than
bank of america it's price to value
it's like price is what you pay value is
what you get
right if you're getting [ __ ] for 200
it's still a bad investment
that's how you break right well pricing
comparison
yeah one of my favorites is like well
[ __ ] man why didn't you go with them
yeah like they're only like [ __ ] man but
like
yeah the one case scenario is like we
did the call
with the guy first and then the next day
he's like i got another company i'm
talking with
blah blah blah he's not with them we
followed up with him he's like yeah i
went with them
because they were like two dollars a
month we were like that's fine and it
happens the thing is is he'll be back
right yeah but the other side of it is
uh because
here's candidly they have no way to
acquire customers
you know they're ltv dude if he keeps
him for a [ __ ] year
it's 2400 right
he's not competition that's kind of my
point here but yeah even if it were and
this did come up right
one of my favorite clothes is called the
comparison close all right which i say
all right
let's pretend price isn't an option all
right let's say we're both priced at the
exact same amount
which one would you rather do they're
gonna say you
right i'd be like why and then they're
gonna be like well you know i like the
fact that you guys got the coaching
thing
uh i mean i like selling higher ticket
that's that kind of makes more sense to
me
they'll start telling you why and you're
like right you like anything else
you keep going anything else any other
reasons anything else like about roi
what about risk what about like track
record any of those things matter well
yeah i guess that too
like right and for that reason you can
understand why we're not 200
as you let them sell you on the reason
of why they would rather do you they
spend three minutes telling you about
why you're better
you're like right you can understand why
we're not 200 yeah
but i like the stock example because
it's listen it's like the price of the
stock is irrelevant it's what you get
for what you pay
if you pay 200 you flush it down the
toilet is that a good deal
of course not if you pay a thousand
dollars and you get 10 back
is that a good deal of course so the
price has nothing to do with our
discussion
but everything to do with how likely you
are to hit your goal
that's good how likely do you think you
are to hit your goal and how important
is your time
do you want to waste three more months
not hitting your goal trying another
mickey mouse thing
do you think if he was really the best
in the industry like let's be real for a
second do you think if he was the best
in the industry
the most likely to help you hit your
goal he would charge you the same amount
as a [ __ ] boot camp client
yes or no [ __ ] hell no
of course not so then why do you think
it would be reasonable that he'd be
better
of course he's not so the question is
are you being cheap are you gonna get
burned twice today
right or do you want to buy nice you can
buy nice or buy twice
right it's up to you